a short time ago in a boardroom close
close to here Disney CEO Bob Iger
described last week's teaser release for
star wars the force awakens as exciting
promising eager moviegoers the film will
exceed their expectations the CEO
praised director JJ Abrams and the new
president of Lucas Films Kathleen
Kennedy for their respective past films
while pushing the storytelling into the
future they're attempting to achieve the
perfect balance between the greatness of
what was and the greatness of what we
believe is to come and I think they have
done that when people see the film they
will agree the film is set for release
on December 18 2015 alright so naturally
we're starting the show this week with
clearly the most important thing
happening on the face of the earth I am
incredibly excited about this almost
everything I believe I learned from Star
Wars I even thought the prequels were
okay I get a lot of [ __ ] for it Jar Jar
Jar as I should as I should all right so
bad I gotta start with you here as the
movie guy uh do you have the faith in
the force that I have with this thing I
have a lot of faith in in in JJ Abrams
um I think the odds are that it will
deliver that fan base apparently as
evidenced by what you just said will
literally watch anything yeah so you
know it seems like it'll be better that
trailer has the feel and you know as a
as a as a movie critic you you don't
wanna make any bold decisions based on a
trailer 1 people will laugh at you into
you're gonna be wrong yeah but come on
be wrong right said yeah it looked good
you know it looked like it was taken
seriously didn't look like a joke I saw
Star Wars three times in 1977 like
everybody else of of my age but that
second and third time I was like yes
we're gonna see Star Wars again cuz this
is what we do cuz we're ten yeah but i
am not that into this really and it is
never meant any that i didn't see the
Empire Strikes Back for 15 years after
came out I saw the first I saw the third
and then I had to cut a piece in and I
call yourself a movie review that is
disturbing Rick how do you feel about
this thing do you think ok so the
prequels everyone gets it they weren't
as good this was George Lucas directing
all of them after writing all the mid
cetera et cetera but now JJ Abrams I'm
sitting
the theater some middle-aged guys around
me roughly my age I'm 60 is another
guy's gray you know sitting there
waiting for the movie to start and they
bring out the trailer and these old
party old guys I'll go what's this and
then jeez they're going along the water
and then we could put a little bit look
look at and then you see then Harrison
Fargo's sure way we're a home that's a
good air isn't for our spaceship that
are with that was Harrison or two by 11
now let's go back up to a joker now he's
old too buddy is he looks exactly got
you know just for just for wookies car
they are so meant that they didn't
change that soon at all yeah yeah so
your point is that the exciting I
haven't seen grown men cry like that
since rake and so is that came out of
the cornfield that was a movie uh right
to the Disney part of this uh but you
know look Lucas Films huge it started
small and it became something huge
Disney's even bigger than that is this
just mean more toys this is me more
mainstream it's probably both I mean
look Disney they they they haven't had
what is it now you know 65 years of
enormous success by accident they know
what they're doing they are professional
movie people uh and this needs to be a
professional movie and if that in this
by the same token we're gonna get
blasted with more Star Wars stuff yeah
okay my cynicism about that has been
completely eroded by reality like that
this is the world we live in and that's
what's gonna happen but the important
thing is what kind of movie they get a
make like if your blasted with product
placement and and and kids are inundated
with Star Wars stuff to buy and video
games that they'd then go with the the
first three movies the prequels well
then then you spin your appropriately
cynical about it you know I would I
don't think any of us were cynical I
certainly wasn't even though then I like
the Star Wars merchandise the little I
had the little action figures yeah um
and those were great I like those a lot
better than I liked the the first three
movies what do you think about the
Disney part of this you think there's a
risk in having just two or three studios
that own
pretty much everything I mean they own
all the Marvel stuff now it's all coming
out of the same factories what I sure
was surprised when they took a gamble
guardians of the galaxy which is like a
really not at the same size franchise by
any means and they dumped a ton of cash
on it it will be running neck and neck
with guardians of the galaxy I think
those will be two competing forces do
you think that it will ever come close
to catching up I know toys why's it
hasn't what's interesting about Star
Wars though with what is that you talk
about those those older men sitting up
and taking notes coming out coming out
of there all right it was me coming out
of there hot coming out of their heart
disease free at the moment that's what
guardians of the galaxy is up against is
this is this multi-generational
penetration that Star Wars there's
enough money for everyone there's plenty
of money going on real quick so is that
what captured your imagination the way
that Star Wars clearly captured mine is
there something that did it for you Star
Wars completely it framed so much what I
think about things is a fiction yeah
thousand and one yeah alright promised
me a decade ago there'd be a civilian
space station and that there would be
Pan Am airlines and I have been
completely betrayed by my culture yeah I
would like to know I mentioned this on
Twitter and I didn't get nearly as much
hate as I thought it would but it is a
little weird going back from the first
movie and apparently from the trailer
that when the x-wing fighters or
whatever they when they shoot in tunnels
at the ships in front of them and they
miss there's never that thing never hits
anything like there's never an explosion
further down the tunnel I mean of where
the ricochets and the random shot ya
gonna hit something actually you're
there's no pooping right you know ray
that's a little complaint so I guess
your answer then is no nothing capture
your imagination because you're so
literal and you want such truth what
captured your imagination the way Star
Wars captured mine let us know in the
comments write down
you